so mad dog Russo lost his mind he gets
on the air and he says if the
Diamondbacks win I'll retire I would not
be stunned if they won tonight I would
be floored I'll say this right now and
Bob racan write it down if they win the
next two games and win this series in
seven games if they win I will I will
retire on a spot mad dog what the [__]
did you do I am in an incredible pickle
I need Mr Stern to go out there and
figure this out so I can make amends the
floor is yours well first of all any
rational person would say why is this my
problem but all right I'm not rational
what were you thinking though saying
you're going to retire if the
Diamondbacks win that's crazy it was a
Flow Away line I did not think in any
shape way of forming by the way the
whole media agreed with me nobody
thought the diamondb win two games so
the idea that this is a crazy prediction
is absurd so I got a [__] plan for
you you ready I'm ready yes I'm ready of
course I'm ready go ahead you got to do
something so
outrageous that they forget about the
fact that you said you were going to
retire over a over a baseball game now
this sounds crazy you come on my show we
put you in a bikini and you walk down
the street with a sign that says I'm a
douche all the way down a whole city
block I believe people would say okay
the guy didn't do it he didn't retire
but you know what he suffered he
suffered that's not the worst idea it'll
be a diamondb bikini I think that's how
you gotta do it you have to have
diamondb I agree I don't do I have and
by the way have to have the sign to
announce it is that I have to go that
crazy I'm gonna tell you something if
you do that everyone will say wow
obviously he couldn't retire but he he
was humiliated he was in a bikini and he
had a sign on that said I'm a douche can
we use a different word than the one you
just described to get point acuse but
it's a little more family oriented can
we do that no you got to be humiliated
Mad Dog let me talk to Mad Dog
impersonator let me see what he says
okay go ahead what do you think of my
idea uh little spotty uh upper body not
rates right now thighs are looking
pretty good I'm using the Thigh Master
Suzanne Summers not bad in that spot we
could get real mad dog what do you think
about what Mad Dog impersonator is
saying well listen for 64 years AG I'm
in decent shape so I'm not so much
worried about wearing a bikini with a
diamondback logo what I am concerned
about is eliminate the term that will is
a little Unbecoming what about I'm a
liar that's better now you're starting
to cook with G how about this how about
this let me make it real embarrassing
I'm a liar and a dope I'm a liar and a
dope all right there okay perfect deal
is done I will I will if you eliminate
that word
I will do liar and dope you will
orchestrate and I will do something else
as a good call for the diamondb
charitable Foundation I think that's
fair too but as far as the public
humiliation I think you hit it right on
thee I'm counting on you to be contact
Mad Dog the only way he gets out of this
is through some humiliation we got it
all planned out you arrange with Mad Dog
when he's going to do this and then
alert the media so he can be publicly
humiliated all right got it got
it